uh roast is the best form of
potato oh chips
chips I what other of potatoes are there
like Cris do you like a dolphin was po
no it's too fancy I think you I think I
could get you into dolphin was
potatoes I didn't know that I was ever
going to say that that sounded overtly
sexual I could get you a doph you can
try I'll
try I never thought I would be saying
that
this lighting what the mashed potatoes
are absolutely disgusting to me I don't
unless it's like like really like
whipped and full of milk no that's
absolutely repulsive to me I'm going to
say I I disagree with it it's not the
best strong but not I correct 49% of
people said that roast is the top tier
49 51 uh chips at second came second
Mash at third were at 10 with 9% of the
vote I didn't even know what they were
to be totally honest